all of the structures that we use to run
the world today our civics our politics
our legal systems health care education
are all structured for world 100 or 200
years ago not for the world of today so
we think we're in for a lot of
disruption hi I'm Tracy Oppenheimer for
reason TV and today I'm talking
whistling Ishmael at the 2013 global
conference in Beverly Hills Salim is the
founding director of singularity
University Celine thanks for talking to
us thanks for having me so what's new
with singularity um well we're
continuing with our programs we have 80
students coming from I think 40
different countries this year this one
kid out of Argentina has gone and
created nano satellites that if you
create a mesh system he wants to launch
about 100 150 these and he will be able
to provide real-time video anywhere on
the planet and his first satellite
launched like three days ago and so
we're seeing some of these projects now
become very real off the drawing board
into reality so it's very exciting talk
about how technology is improving on an
exponential level now you're witnessing
it firsthand yeah we've been seeing the
exponential growth in computing for now
50 60 years Moore's Law we're now seeing
that same paradigm happen in a whole
series of other technologies a our
robotics nanotech 3d printing it we've
seen forty percent growth in personal
computers year-on-year for 40 years if
you had that same growth and say the top
speed of a car today a car would go 500
light-years in speed and so that
computational capability is now leaching
into your smartphone's into our bodies
into everything that we do our memories
are not in our heads anymore right there
in our smartphones so how do we think
about the world as we turn it into
information and when you have an
information-based environment we've
recognized that it goes into this
exponential growth pattern and the
barrier to entry seems to be a lot lower
these days you're a big fan of
crowdfunding so talk about what this is
and why you're optimistic about it yeah
you know used to take kind of 20 million
dollars to create a company with all of
the computers and servers and team etc
then about about up to about 10 years
ago cost about 10 million dollars today
it's like a hundred thousand dollars
that means that that many more people
can have access to it and as we get to
crowdfunding which means that anybody
with a great idea can be funded for that
idea no matter where they are in the
world
it democratizes the environment we
create a pure meritocracy and so one of
the biggest issues that VCS or investors
have with companies as market wrestle we
don't know whether a particular product
is going to make it in the marketplace
and with crowdfunding you have market
validation and we've just never had that
before and so there's there'll be some
kinks as we work out the mechanics of it
but this looks like the most exciting
development in financing and funding in
50 years in layman's terms you're
basically saying that because the risk
is so much more spread out it makes it a
lot more of these projects just do a
bolda and try exactly and we've seen
from history that it success comes from
not the quality of a project but how
many projects there are if you have a
hundred companies one of them will
succeed and so if we have more companies
out there we'll get that many more home
runs and we think this will be a major
driver of the economy in the next couple
of decades this seems to be a trend not
just with technology if you look at
journalism with bloggers there's no
editor now if you have good content
we're gonna get your can get an audience
and that's really all it takes now so
did you say this isn't limited just to
technology that you can see this
elsewhere oh it's happening across
industries you know the first few were
newspapers and music and electronic
publishing those are the first three
domains fully information enabled now
we're moving to cars being information
enabled the new Tesla is essentially an
app you download an update every week so
we're moving into that world when we
start seeing that you know that
something funky is happening and we're
turning pretty much everything into a
computational basis but at the same time
there's a lot more government barriers
and regulations so what if your
experience has been with this especially
on an international scale oh this is
probably the biggest structural issue
that we have in the world today and and
not to rail on government but
fundamentally the the obligation to
provide public safety is important and
we don't know what the implications are
a genetically modified foods or new
types of treatments and it takes time to
figure out the clinical trials and yet
the world is moving very very fast one
of the big questions that we're asking
right now is how does any regulatory
framework keep pace with technology as
its accelerating away from us right
we've lost the whole music digital music
thing the patent system is fundamentally
broken privacy is washing away in front
of our eyes by the time the FDA
regulates a drug today the drug is out
of date if you're studying and master's
degree in one of the areas that we teach
advanced robotics or biotech or
neuroscience by the time you finish your
degree you're out of date and we've
never seen that in the world before that
our ability to teach a subject can't
keep pace with them amount of changes in
that subject area so we have to evolve
entirely new mechanisms to keep pace
with this new world all of the
structures that we use to run the world
today our civics our politics our legal
systems health care education are all
structured for world 100 or 200 years
ago not for the world of today so and we
think we're in for a lot of disruption
and our kind of reason for existence is
to train a new generation of leaders to
how to navigate right well thank you
again for talking jeseline thanks for
having me great to have freezing TV I'm
Tracy Oppenheimer